hey Samuel lives here and on this video
I'm gonna explain to you exactly how you
can buy a house without any down payment
[Music]
this may sound too good to be true to
you and if you think it's too good to be
true and it can't be done then normally
you're probably right however I've done
this countless countless countless times
on buying houses all the time even today
without using a down payment so as many
of my success students and you can see
that on winners on a Wednesday the
success students are so successful that
they're making newspapers so this really
is real this really is true
in fact there's not just one way how to
buy properties without a down payment
there's actually lots and lots of ways
for example you can buy a house now but
pay for it later like you can do this
with a lot of stuff you can buy cars
this way you can buy products this way
but you can actually buy houses on a buy
now pay later basis but the great thing
about buying houses that way is you get
the rent and you benefit from the
capital appreciation without even
actually having paid for it another way
is you can borrow money so you can do
buy properties without using any of your
money without putting a down payment
down yourself but you can borrow other
people's money or money from banks and
different places again this is an
incredible strategy to buy properties
without using any of your own money we
call it leverage you can also joint
venture so you can find the house you
can do the work you can bring the
expertise to the table and then you can
find a joint venture partner who also
wants to buy a property he wants to buy
a house as an investment he's got the
money but that's all he's got he hasn't
got any knowledge he doesn't have any
credentials all all street savviness
around what's going on whereas if you
bring that to the table you don't have
to bring the money to the table you can
also buy a property and you can put
money in but then add value to the
property and then pull that money out by
leaving no downpayment in the property
so you really really can do this and
there's many many many ways to do it I'm
doing it all the time
however on this video I wanted to
specifically talk about joint ventures
because I think this is one of the most
exciting
simple ways to buy properties without
using any of your own moment it also
means that you haven't got to pay for it
later you haven't got to pay anybody
back it you've literally got a property
using none of your own money and you've
done that with a joint venture partner
so how does this work exactly well
firstly in order to do this you've got
to be a good deal sorcerer you've got to
be an expert at finding good property
deals because there's no way that
anyone's gonna want to put all the money
and give you 50% of the profits
unless you've earned the right as a good
property sorcerer so that's the first
thing second thing is if you do in joint
ventures make sure that you've got
firstly clarity with the joint venture
partner ie what's going to happen what
are the expectations what are the exit
strategies so you've got clarification
but also get a solicitor to draw up a
contract which they're one of the most
stupid things is to do business with
somebody especially when you're talking
tens hundreds of thousands of pounds on
the table without any solicitor involved
because when there's a lot of money on
the table and properties always go up in
value you just want to be clear you want
to go solicitor evolve even if you're
dealing with family so let me give you a
couple of examples I'm gonna give you an
example
warm with me being the person that was
the the expert that found the deal that
didn't put any money in and you might
say what idiot would put all the money
in and give someone fifty percent like
fifty percent for finding the deal what
idiot but then I'm gonna give you
another example of when I put all the
money in and only took fifty percent
because you see joint ventures although
it can result in you buying property
without any down payment it doesn't mean
that someone is getting screwed over
property investing has a lot of money in
it it's a big parlay and you could
afford to cut different pieces of the
pie where there's lots of people that
win so we're not dealing with something
where there's only a few pounds to be
made and one person takes it all and the
loser gets nothing in property there's
always winners and winners not winners
and losers because there's so much money
to be made so one example is about four
years ago I'm just been on a buying
spree I've bought a lot of properties
I've just got married so I spent a lot
of money getting how
and going on honeymoon and stuff like
that and I came across this absolute gem
of a property it was a thigh bed HMO and
this was in Wolverhampton and the the
owner contacted me and said that they
owned it in a partnership the
partnership was split up and they needed
to get rid of this hmm real fast they
were selling yet 27 percent below market
value the cash flow was incredible and
they said Samuel we don't want to mess
around we just want a quick sale we've
got some personal things going on will
you buy it so I negotiated the price
27 percent below market value the
problem was I didn't have enough money
to buy the property whose I was
literally cashless I've got money tied
up in property but I didn't have the
money in my pocket or in my bank to go
ahead and buy this property so I said
look if I was to give you X would you
accept they said yes and I'm not
thinking I haven't got the money now I
could have just passed it on to somebody
else and said I can't buy this house
it's a great house it's a great
investment I'll pass it on to somebody
and I'll charge a finder's fee maybe
I'll make three thousand pounds but the
problem was I was too greedy to do that
because I couldn't let this property
slip from my fingertips but at the same
time I didn't have any money so what do
you do when you've got no money but you
don't want to let good property deal
slip from your fingertips for the and
just get paid a few thousand pounds as a
finder's fee what I did was like
contacting somebody that I know this
person had money that had no idea about
property investing but they did want to
invest they were they were frustrated
with their money sat in the bank earning
them no return and they trusted me they
knew me they knew my reputation
experience as a property investor so I
said I thought this property if you put
the money in which is about thirty
thirty nine thousand pounds plus refurb
you talking about fifty thousand pounds
if you put the money in what all do is
we can have a joint venture whereby
we'll get 50% of any of the future
capital appreciation on the property and
50/50 profit on the rent you put them on
the end the money that you put in is
yours but any profits down the line on
that property is 50/50 what
think they work for it because 50% of
this deal was more than a hundred
percent of a deal that they could find
so what am i bringing to the table or I
bring in to the table expertise great
property deals bargain prices high
return what are they bringing to the
table will they're bringing to the table
all of the money for me no down payment
that property now has we making a
thousand pounds a month 500 for me 500
to them caps appreciations got up really
well I think it's gone up by almost a
hundred thousand pounds fifty thousand
for me fifty thousand for them how much
did I put down no nothing no down
payment so that's one way joint venture
the other end of the table because some
people might say Samuel that's me you
shouldn't you should have taken 50% just
for finding the deal no it's not I have
been on the other end of the table I had
one of my students come to me and say
Samuel I found a deal the deal was a
fantastic deal it needed very little
money in about 16 thousand pounds that's
all the leaks put in they said to me
Samuel can you lend me the sixteen
thousand pounds and they offered to give
me ten percent I said I don't want ten
percent I don't want to give you sixteen
thousand to get ten percent ten percent
is very very weak the property was
getting a lot more than twenty percent
so I said look how about this
you found the property it's a great
property in your area you know the area
you're planning on managing the property
and everything like that how about this
I'll put the sixteen thousand it up all
money in you just manage it and do what
you need to do with it you found it you
take complete responsibility of it and
we'll go 50/50 on the profits they were
delighted sometimes I put all the money
in other terms all I might put no money
in the bottom line is you do not need
money to buy property you need knowledge
you need experience you need the ability
to act and implement what you're
learning as well so that's two
adventures again if you do this make
sure you do it properly make sure you
have a solicitor draw up the contracts
there's ways you can do this whereby you
can set up a company where you earn the
company together some of you have 100
percent a shares some of you have 100
percent B shares so depending on who put
the money it depends on who gets what
shares it's very simple we
you need to know what you're doing so
what I would say is if you're ready to
take action if you're ready to buy
properties but you haven't got a lot of
money get the knowledge read the books
watch all the videos on this YouTube
channel come and join me at a property
investors crash course but whatever you
do don't take yourself out the game
because you can do this we've got us of
where you are right now hey guys hope
you enjoyed that video there's a lot of
ways to buy property without using any
money so do check out some of the other
videos that we have in our playlists and
also don't forget to subscribe
what that notifications buy them so you
never miss a video thank you so much
[Music]